so hello everybody i'm really excited to
be here with nathan jacobs i met nathan
several years ago as he was uh putting
together a movie called becoming fully
human
um it was really exciting to see that he
was aware of the spiritual crisis that
we're going through let's say in the
west and he was trying to kind of talk
about it and propose some solutions but
nathan is also a scholar who's
associated uh with several universities
he's written papers books he is a visual
artist he makes paintings and
illustrations commercial art and
ultimately he's also a movie maker in
also in a narrative sense where he has
made a
just a regular story movie and he's also
working on some projects now so i think
he's the perfect person to talk about
the moment right now the moment in
culture re-enchantment and how christian
spirituality is related to that
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
nathan thanks for thanks for joining me
in this conversation i'm happy that you
uh were able to find some time to talk
to me yeah my pleasure i'm uh it's it's
been a while but i'm glad that we're
able to talk so
so maybe tell people a little bit like a
very
quick uh i mean it's difficult because
your journey is extremely complex but
maybe tell people a little bit about
your journey of how you connect your art
making with the scholarship and also
with your own spiritual path towards
orthodoxy
sure yeah that is a long journey i'll
see how briefly
this is a long form you know yes it is a
long-form discussion okay but i'll try
to not spend all of it on that
uh so i'm i'm sort of uh
i suppose you could say i'm an artist
turned scholar turned filmmaker which i
really see is the convergence of those
other two phases of my life uh so in
terms of art i started in fine art a
very classical sort of fine arts
painting and drawing with maryland
institute college of art baltimore
um where i study that and uh and and
that was really sort of my
what i was all about right uh the visual
arts
but then what happened for me is uh i
ended up going into a type of
existential spiritual crisis
specifically asking questions about
immortality
the afterlife god whether i have free
will things like that um and that was uh
induced
rather peculiar i'll skip that story but
i'll suffice it to say i was very
interested in things like
hallucinogenics and those played a heavy
role in awakening those questions in me
and that started me down this
road of
inquiry about philosophy and religion
and that road took a lot of twists and
turns
i had a christian background my mother
was a missouri senate lutheran so very
conservative form of german lutheran um
you know her being german
lutheran uh and then uh but you know
over time and my father was not anything
which uh you know sort of created a
certain dissonance in home obviously
certain things being instilled by her
but that created at least an inkling she
was very interested in apologetic so i'd
heard arguments in favor of christianity
and christ and things like that so i
took that seriously as something to be
considered
but as i dove into historical
christianity and sort of going down to
its roots largely in the roots of
western christianity started in august
and sort of worked my way out into the
ancient influences and philosophy and
then forwarded to the way that developed
in scholastic philosophy and then on
into modernity uh the more i became
disillusioned with christianity actually
and over time became an opponent of it
nonetheless i had certain spiritual
inklings about the world i was convinced
that god existed i was convinced also
that there was a significance to christ
but i just wasn't quite sure what that
really looked like
and so my own views were very
um
i suppose the charitable
reading would be idiosyncratic uh the
young charitable one would be heretical
uh
but nonetheless uh i i dove into all
these different philosophies and um and
that that journey went through you know
bachelors of philosophy and masters and
in church history and systematic
theology and things like that on into
phds
uh a pair of phds and so i i ended up
doing that whole journey
um and along the way sort of started out
hopeful that maybe there was something
in christianity became an opponent of
christianity an advocate of the god of
the philosophers and all sorts of ideas
that would not be in keeping with
historical christianity until in my
doctoral studies i discovered the easter
church fathers
and i recognized this radical difference
between the worldview i was reading
about there and what i had studied for
years in in western christianity
and that initially just intrigued me in
its own right because i thought i had
mastered the systems of christian
thinking and so what on earth am i
staring at here uh so at first it was
just intrigue and then over time the
more i dove into it and explored well
specifically metaphysics uh metaphysics
is my area of main interest
um and the metaphysics that was there uh
over time i became persuaded of the
worldview itself and then when i
discovered it was still a lived
practice right there was actually an
orthodox church gorgeous orthodox church
only two blocks from where i lived at
the time so i went in there and saw sure
enough i sort of scrutinized it because
i was skeptical that there was still a
through line you know between what i've
been reading in ancient writers and that
but sure enough there was
uh that ended up sucking me in and you
know you fast forward seven years later
and i'm an orthodox christian
um but along the way also in there i had
this convergence with film where i had
this opportunity i had always loved
movies and i loved the idea of making
movies
uh and it was for a variety of reasons
part of it was because i saw them as
sort of the contemporary cathedrals
right these these works of art that
required so many different artists and
skill sets and talents to come together
which is why all those credits are there
in the end
that come together and make something
that one person can make on their own
and so i just love that and i love that
mode of storytelling and all that uh but
it's you know who does that for a living
that's not a real job right like people
don't
really do those sorts of
things uh
but um i had this opportunity because of
certain
artists i was meeting in the in the film
world along the way in my journey of
studying philosophy and theology
who were impressed with my talents i had
a background you know in not only art
but i paid the bills during my time of
you know academic study in the
commercial arts arena doing digital art
as you mentioned i was a 3d character
modeler
i did i worked in the video game
industry
uh and uh and so they saw my work and
they were impressed with that they were
willing to work with me and so at some
point i just couldn't resist that the
idea of i get to make a movie so um its
own long story but i pulled together
a team and resources and all this and
eventually so did the heavy lifting get
off the ground my first feature
narrative movie which was killing poe
uh this um
which is an ensemble college comedy um
it's nicely layered the way like a wes
anderson movie is layered but it's not
um it's not terribly deep i wouldn't
point to it as you know this is you know
rich philosophical content even though i
think it's a good movie
but
all of those things once i had you sort
of fast forward i'm an orthodox
christian i'm a college professor i'm
well published in philosophy you know in
areas like not only modern philosophy
like immanuel kant so that also ancient
philosophy in the church college
um and i've made a movie now
uh what emerged was a group came to me
who was interested in this trend and
culture considering they're religiously
unaffiliated and they said you seem like
a great candidate to
do something on this right because
you well first of all your former nun
right religiously unaffiliated
i suppose i should define that right the
nuns n-o-m-e-s right people who have no
religious affiliation
as opposed to like a catholic man
um you always need to get that out of
the way in this in this topic but um so
they came to me about that trend and
they said you know you're a former nun
you know you're an orthodox christian
now um
you you teach in colleges so you have
exposure to this demographic or you know
at least a large portion of this
demographic uh you're an artist you're a
filmmaker
we'd be curious to see what you would do
with this topic and so i pitched a
really sort of an experimental
documentary type film that would look at
this group and open up a discussion both
for the nuns themselves and for folks
who are religiously affiliated
and and lo and behold they said they'd
finance it
and that's what became becoming truly
human
which was the documentary that you
referred to and i thought that was just
going to be this sort of brief aside
where i stepped out of academia for a
year hit pause i was teaching at
university of kentucky at the time in
the philosophy department
and then i just go back to teaching but
anyway that just sort of opened doors
where folks said we really like what you
do and your unique voice in film and
we'd like to get behind you and
and so i decided to take the risk of
jumping out and saying well i'll keep
sort of affiliated in the academy and
continue to publish and speak and things
like that but i'm going to try to try to
try this road in film because i love the
convergence of ideas and art in this
storytelling genre and so anyway fast
forward now um you know i have an
arrangement i now do this for a living i
have a first look deal
uh with a
a subsidiary of of lionsgate right the
movie studio uh and i'm working on a
host of other projects that are in
development now
um so i still publish i still speak uh
i'm associated with vanderbilt uh
divinity school specifically their arts
and culture program over there um but i
suppose i suppose i can say i now make
movies for a living or something like
that anyway yeah which is great which is
a crazy thing to say in a certain manner
because like you said not a lot of
people get to say that so that's one
yeah
that's right so so there you have it
that's me
and so
i think that you're really at an
interesting point of convergence you
know i
a lot of the people that are watching
this video have been
feeling this change in culture let's say
a return of narrative they've been
noticing it a return a kind of
re-enchantment in the world
and noticing how
let's say storytelling especially how
right now in hollywood in a lot of the
movies that are coming out there's a lot
of politics in it there's a lot of
almost propaganda like it's pushing
towards certain ideologies and
everything uh and realizing that good
storytelling is one of the solutions to
that problem um and how so how do you
see that what is your perception let's
say of the place of storytelling right
now in culture and how we how it can
affect the world
uh yeah i mean i do think that one of
the things that you're trying that
you're starting to see is this this
shift in how
um folks uh take in information and so
much of that has to do with the the
general impressions the fact that we can
sort of dive into and become engrossed
in in an entire world uh that you know
and and by an entire world i mean on the
on the one hand that that goes to things
like video games right we have these
essentially virtual worlds and obviously
we're moving into things like metaverse
where it's even more so
uh but even i would say when you look at
things like the the i the phenomena of
binge watching where you end up being
able to tell long storm
long-form storytelling uh in episodic
ways uh that's a totally new phenomenon
and actually just sort of on that one of
the show i'm working on a show
which i don't think i'm at the liberty
to say what it is but we're we're in the
midst of writing season one um which
will hopefully be launching
uh probably a year from now
but i it was such a shift in my mind
from everything i'd learned about movie
writing you know script writing to uh to
writing for an episodic series because
in movie writing you're always up
against this script you know
page limit right you go over 100 pages
right and if you can come in under that
that's great and usually that means a
lot of condensing every line has to be
very precise and get rid of that thing
here and where can we cut
whereas as soon as i started working on
an episodic series it was strange to
realize you get to just sit there and
live with characters and let them have
inconsequential conversations in insofar
as you're just developing these
characters i actually remember the first
notes i got back on the first
episodic script i wrote was hey could
you add could you add this one like long
contemplative speech in this part here
where they meander about about i thought
i've never received a note anything like
that can you add a disposable speech
that's them contemplating you know the
existential place in which they find
themselves
but that's part of the whole you know
inhabiting those worlds and getting to
know those characters in a way that you
can't in the shorter form of
storytelling and so i think what you're
starting to see in in in those areas as
well is something that used to be
restricted to
novels right you wouldn't be able to do
that in a movie because it was just
people didn't have the attention span
for it plus it was typically in a
theater right
the technology has advanced in a way uh
where we're starting to to be surrounded
with those sorts of opportunities to
engage in those worlds uh and so i think
what you're starting to see is that the
ways in which people take in story
and see the world and inhabit worlds and
find characters that they identify with
and get to know
is really revolutionized
by on the one hand the technology and
the place in which we find ourselves in
history but then i think even kovit has
changed it even further because people
were forced into their homes and what
did they retreat to
uh and so sitting here on the inside of
sort of
the movie industry i'm hearing all the
conversations that are taking place
about whether or not theatrical is
forever changed and sort of forever in a
different place if not dead you know and
whether episodic and all these sort of
streaming things are are the new way to
go um which on the one hand is
disruptive and scary for folks who have
nostalgia for movies like me i love
going to the movie theater uh on the
other hand uh i think it's actually
going to amplify in some ways the ways
in which we take in story and taken
story in a long form
uh that is much different than what we
typically have in the past in this sort
of visual media and so on so
i don't know if that goes to the
question that you're asking i mean i
think kind of
maybe one of the things that
i've seen grow in the past 20 years
maybe 10 years even more so is something
like fandoms for example
so
one of the things you see in fandoms is
you see people who attribute identity to
these fictional worlds they attribute
they put their identity into
into these kind of uh
whatever it's manga or whatever it's
star wars and all these different
fictional worlds and they have a desire
to a certain extent to participate and
so the whole aesthetic of the of fan
fiction
the whole aesthetic of cosplay um and
one of the things that i've noticed is
that this seems to be marking
a difference from just passive
entertainment where people are looking
to find worlds in which to inhabit
because in a way they are dealing with
the nuns problem that is they're dealing
with a lack of cosmic story in which
they can participate
um which is something christianity
afforded us and now they because the
scientific kind of materialist world
doesn't have much that to offer you have
a you have a scientific materialist type
who's obsessed with like
my little pony or like or star wars or
whatever it is that people get obsessed
with um
and so that's been my kind of reflection
about how
people are starting to notice how
stories are
that world building in the fictional
sense is actually something which exists
in our actual life and we need as a a
narrative frame to to in which we can
inhabit
yeah well i noticed this in a slightly
different way actually initially not
because of so much film but as much as
the the research with the nuns
so um and this kind of goes to a project
that i've been i'm that is currently in
well it's more than in development it's
sort of in the financing stage in
preparation for production
but and again i can't really say
specifics about what it is but i think
the background of it uh sort of goes to
this and was the first time i was
awakened to the phenomena that you're
talking about
um so when i was working on becoming
truly human um you've seen it obviously
i don't i won't presume that everybody
who's listening to this has seen it uh
but there's a series of interviews with
nuns right this group of nuns that's
supposed to be a representative sample
of uh folks who are religiously
unaffiliated
and uh in preparation for that you know
me and my producer we went out and we
screened interviewed i don't know 60
plus religiously unaffiliated folks
uh with sort of standard form types of
questions that we wanted to know where
they stand on this investment
and uh over time in that data gathering
there was this sort of odd data point
that emerged out of the process one that
i it doesn't show up in the documentary
but it definitely made an impression on
me
which was that a 100
of the nuns that i interviewed believed
in ghosts
and that was a surprise to me and what
was especially surprising was okay in
general the nuns are not atheists right
so 90 of the nuns on my finding and
that's actually the same with pew
uh in their finding
uh 90 of them believe in at least god or
a higher power only 10 would identify as
atheists but even the atheists right who
were like i don't believe in god science
science science my apartment is haunted
right
and i thought that was so bizarre and so
interesting that i thought
you know even the atheists believe in
the government in god or not i'm sorry
maybe even the agent that was completely
incorrect even the atheists believe in
ghosts right
i thought well so this is is this an
anomaly right of my sample but then i
saw this this uh article i think it was
in new york magazine
um by clay rutledge sociologist who had
also studied the nuns
and um and the article was titled
something like that don't believe in god
how about ufos
and uh and the whole article was about
the fact that if you think who the nuns
are are scientific materialist
mechanical philosophers
you know or something like that you
don't understand who the nuns are
and he talked about his entire study was
about
how um the sort of the way in which
as folks diverge from religion there's
this increased interest in the
paranormal and the occult and that was
what his entire study was on and so
looking at his research i saw that he
saw the same pattern there
and um and it's interesting because one
of the patterns that you began to see
there was well there were really two
things that that clay identified which i
had also noticed the one is that as the
narrative of religion was diverged from
there was a different search for a
cosmic narrative that began to fill in
there was was a sort of ad-hoc worldview
being formed concerning karma or fate
right the cosmos bringing about certain
certain things to me right that are
meaningful uh there was a belief that
the world itself is spiritual there's
the the belief that our world is haunted
right and some of those spirits are good
some are evil um
and uh and then and and that was sort of
that paranormal occult uh sort of world
view
uh was what started to fill in that gap
and uh and it wasn't only just ghosts
right in paranormal culture there's
several subcultures right there's alien
culture there's cryptozoology you know
culture and uh and what you're starting
to see if you pay attention to the
subcultures is them talking to each
other and starting to form new
narratives based on the ways in which
well maybe you know maybe there's
there is a spiritual dimension to the
mothman and it's not just some sort of
strange crypto
uh creature or something like that
anyway you're starting to see these new
narratives uh emerge out of that um from
the the dialogue between them
uh but but one of the things that's also
interesting is in in rutledge's research
what he was looking at specifically was
also the connection between the
subjective sense of meaningfulness
and the delving into the paranormal and
the occult and what he found was there
was an inverse relationship
um where the you know the more you went
into the paranormal and the occult
the lower your sense of subjective
meaning went um
and that's not surprising to me because
i believe the occult is demonic
and so
so if it's really true that that's a
spiritual vacuum of darkness right and
the deeper you go into it the less you
know meaning you should feel right it
should cause that sort of vacuum-like
state
um and but what rutledge also you know
at least speculates about is that then
the turn towards certain social issues
like social activism or whatever it may
be
starts to become the new sort of phase
on the heels of that right as the
paranormal and the occult begins to
disappoint and fail to provide a
satisfying narrative uh there's a new
narrative that emerges that you know
sort of drives you in that direction
um and then also i would point to there
was a dissertation i'm blanking on the
name but i could dig it up dissertation
that i looked at in uh standing grand
rapids not in grand rapids in michigan
someplace
anyway but on reconversion of nuts so
folks myself who ultimately ended up
turning to religion and the ways in
which uh ultimately their final turn you
know when they finally discover a
religion that they can embrace they they
embrace it fully much more fully than a
lot of the folks who are culturally this
or that
religion uh and with that all of a
sudden their beliefs
uh you know adjust right so if they were
you know heavily
you know
let's say left leaning in their politics
also they might abandon some of those
things as they engage in certain uh
religious beliefs because those were
actually symptomatic
of the search for something else it
wasn't that those beliefs were driving
them and so what you see is you see all
these phases of of narrative trading
going on whereas the religion is
providing one sort of
storytelling and way of looking at the
world paranormal comes to fill in the
gap when you abandon that if that fails
you turn to a certain social narrative
and if you rediscover religion you
quickly abandon that one too
uh and i think all of this really does
go to the point that you're talking
about of the sense that the idea of
having some sort of framework by which
to understand the world some sort of
storytelling that holds it all together
and uh and places me within
in a story uh it seems to be something
that humans just absolutely need we
can't get away from right it's it's it's
part of our very
essential nature to look at the world in
that in that way
yeah you're totally right you know the
just just now was it uh klaus schwab
just published his latest book called
the great narrative
and so it's like the world economic
forum basically telling us the primacy
of narrative and how the world needs a
story you know in which to inhabit in
order to kind of get through our our
problems and it's and it's like yeah
they realize that this is necessary now
the question is what will that story be
it's interesting like you said that the
what we get let's say as christianity
wanes although at first it looks like
atheism it ends up being something more
like a kind of confused or broken down
paganism of all these stories and and
conflicting narratives and the fact that
people are obsessed with unexplained
phenomena right so it's like an
unexplained phenomena can obviously not
give you united meaning it's the very
name unexplained phenomena is that
you're constantly peering out in the
darkness like with squinted eyes and
trying to figure out what these with
these things are um
you know and so so obviously it's going
to lead to this kind of
this kind of breakdown in meaning that
people experience or the kind of a kind
of weird nihilism that still believes in
ghosts and and all these strange
phenomena right i mean i do think this
is an interesting miscontemporary
misunderstanding of mystery right
because oftentimes what folks who are
are interested in that that sort of
unexplained phenomena uh it's mystery
is something that draws them in and yet
when you look at the concept of mystery
in the ancient world sure you know uh
you know like this concept you know the
mystery that the word itself you know
originally like
it's it's it's a verb that means to shut
and it and and it refers to the mystery
cults right the initiation into mystery
belts where you check your eyes your
mouth the initiation ritual um
and that's where you know plato starts
to use that to refer to the mysterious
one which is basically the initiated
it's not the person who doesn't see
right it's the person who's been
initiated so they are familiar with the
mysteries and then in christianity and
clement of alexandria for example uh
mystery then starts to be tied with
people who again are initiated and are
gnostics in the good sense right in the
sense they're in the know
um and they all of a sudden are able to
see patterns that were there before so
when you look at the old testament texts
uh there are cryptic strange stories
about people drowning and and you know
and giants and all sorts of bizarre
stuff and what does all this mean
and uh and at least the way clement and
then you know origin does the same thing
uh the way they look at it is that those
stories uh like in the icon of the
transfiguration
uh where christ you know goes up on
mount tabor and he's he's transfigured
and the apostles are there or certain
apostles are there who see this
uncreated light and then moses and
elijah are also there in the bathing
sort of spiritual reading of that was
that uh the texts of the you know the
law and the prophets are just cryptic
texts the true meaning of which
is evasive unless
you actually see them bathed in the
light of christ and so having been
initiated you being the initiated ones
into the mysteries actually now are in a
position to understand what the patterns
are there you can actually see them
properly
and so the irony is oftentimes people
today will completely misuse the term
mystery because it means that stuff that
nobody really knows as opposed to what
it actually meant which was you're
initiated to know the stuff that people
otherwise wouldn't
yeah and i mean i think the fact that
there's a notion that it's uh it's
hidden or that it's secret or that it's
it's a mystery and even in this
there's a little bit of the way we
understand it now which is that the the
insight you get is beyond rational
discourse and it's more experiential and
so once you have that insight you can't
you can't communicate it at the level of
the insight that you have and like you
said then through that perception and
light you can then see the patterns in
the world whereas the occultist and the
cryptic zoologist is only obsessed with
it's it's almost the opposite right it's
always the opposite it's like facing all
these things that i can't understand out
here in the world all these phenomena
that are opaque and thinking that that's
the that's the mystery it's like if i
could understand the mechanical
causality right of bigfoot like if i
could understand what species he is
then i would like what like what would
it hurt
actually he would cease to be
interesting right he would cease to be
interested
if i could understand the mechanics like
if i could add bigfoot to the
encyclopedia like all right but then
okay like i that's very much the
opposite of of uh of like you said this
this idea of moving into the
moving into the initiated uh mystery of
uh you know of the light of the divine
let's say that you find in the ancient
stories
it's very fascinating to see the
opposite like i have a
right in my town they opened the school
of witchcraft like it's like a
two-minute walk from my house you know
and you can see it like just how
just and it's also it's also the like
the everything people criticized about
christianity you know is just there in
your face it's all about application
it's like you know can i get this like
what can i do to get this for myself
like can i get this
some something that they want like a
lover or or something and you think wow
man it's the
all the things that people accuse
christianity of is all there and this
weird occult stuff
but it's lacking
the higher principle that unites it all
together into like one coherent uh story
so that's right yeah very interesting
yeah
um yeah and i i suppose one last thing
on this i mean one of the things that i
noticed uh early on when i first started
looking at the religiously unaffiliated
was it was interesting to me to see the
perception
of the phenomena by um well but both on
the one hand sort of
classical apologist old school sort of
boomers um evangelical types
and then um and then on the other side
the new atheists and they both were
interpreting the data the same way which
was that they're like okay
this means that there is a dispute going
on between christianity and atheism
and um
because those are the only two
apparently talking but there's a dispute
going on between those two and uh and
the atheists are winning and now this
large spike means that they're all
becoming atheists right thanks to the uh
the
the uh
insightful arguments of the new atheists
uh and what was fascinating to me when i
looked at that is i realized two things
first of all uh that's not true
and incidentally just as aside before i
finish this point it is interesting that
with my documentary which sort of gives
a platform to to the um
to uh
to
the the nuns uh the people who hate it
the most are the new atheists on the one
hand and the you know very staunch
evangelicals yeah because they're
they're of the same nature they are the
same nature
and they're looking for the same thing
right they're expecting to hear the same
thing and so when it completely
disappoints in that sense uh you know
they're really upset because it doesn't
reinforce what they're expecting to hear
which they're expecting to hear exactly
that right there's been this debate and
new atheists are winning there's just no
good answers and so on um but i think
the the more accurate uh assessment of
what's going on is that there's a real
sense in which the new atheists and the
classical sort of evangelical apologists
they are cut from the same cloth they're
just modernists there's nothing you're
going to find in that discussion that
you can't find in john locke and bishop
barkley and you know
and uh you know spinoza and hume and
whoever right it's a modernist
discussion just sort of
reheated
and put into the into the culture
in its final phase we could say
it's in its final phase and so the
problem is though the nuns it's not that
the nuns are looking at the discussion
saying oh i think these guys are winning
over here
um
they just don't connect with it they're
not modernists
and so what's happened is not that one
side is winning the debate it's that
both sides have lost the audience
and so what you get is these nuns who
these folks who have disconnected
they're like well i don't connect with
the the faith i was
raised in there's something that's sort
of missing there and which i do think is
a mythologizing piece that you mentioned
and so i've disconnected and gone on
this journey but i also don't connect
just as just as much i don't connect
with the new atheists right that that's
something i didn't connect with either
and so i think what you find is the nuns
are really because they don't have a
clear guide through those things they're
just certain spiritual ships at sea
and i think that there's something good
and there's something bad that's emerged
out of that i think the good thing is
that they
function on what you might call
intuitions right so there's certain
moral intuitions that there is right and
wrong now they're not doing it super
sort of
analytically
right but they have this vague sense
that there really is real right and
wrong they have a vague sense there's
meaning in the world they have a vague
sense that meeting the what they mean by
karma is obviously not
you know
an escape from a cycle of rebirth
because most of them are unsure what
happens when you die so uh but they do
mean like what goes around comes around
right uh good deeds and somehow come
back to you in the cosmos and things
like that and so there they have this
intuition that justice and reward is
somehow tied into this whole system so
they have these they have a sense of the
world is spiritual that they're
spiritual they don't really know what to
do with that on a practical level but
there's all these sort of vague
intuitions and i think um on the one
hand i think there's something good
and right about that right i think we
are not just minds and so
when we function like rationalists who
neglect these other sort of ways of
intuiting things about the world we
really neglect something very important
about understanding the world and so
there's something to be said that's
positive there but i think the problem
is just like if it's you're purely a
rationalist and you ignore those things
uh if it's just intuitions without the
guide of reason or anything like that
you run into other problems and that's
where you just get neopaganism which is
exactly you know what you're talking
about there yeah and the kind of new age
mush or people you know falling into
gurus and
all that kind of stuff is just yeah it's
a it's just all these different things
that are going on as the christian
narrative is being pulled out of society
we're seeing all these things going on
but i i do feel like there is a at least
i've seen in the past few years
there's been a new space that's been
opening up for
let's say for talking about christianity
in in a new way or it's not a new way
it's really the old way but it's it's
right
it's the new way that it's the way that
people haven't heard which is exactly
let's say i imagine the same fathers
that you discovered saying gregory saint
maximus the confessor all these fathers
seem to be offering
a
a solution to the to the problem like to
the problem of consciousness even the
problem of you know the limit of the
viewer all these questions that are
happening in the different fields we can
find in someone like say maximus you
know i did a conversation with uh father
maximus constance just a few weeks ago
about zamax as a confessor i was really
surprised like it went up until it went
up to like twenty thousand views super
fast i'm like this is a bit opaque a
subject but no it's not to make a
subject like say maximus is really key
to to the issues that we're go that
we're uh
that we're uh dealing with now and so i
mean maybe you can talk a little bit
about
how your encounter with the church
fathers let's say
shifted your own worldview and how it
kind of led you out of this this of the
rationalist
mind
yeah yeah i mean now that's a that's a
big topic but sure let's let's see why
not
let's give it a whirl
um
so uh i think you know for me there were
there were a couple of different things
that was happening and i don't know that
i could talk about the way they they
were such an antidote to where i was at
without talking about exactly where i
was at
um so when i delve into um
you know historical christianity
optimistically like i said i thought
there's some significance to the person
of christ i'm pretty sure that's true
um so maybe you know maybe delving into
historical christianity will be the
right road to get to whatever it is that
i'm i'm looking for
but it was heavily disappointing and i
think one of the things as i dove into
um western christianity
i started finding certain patterns in
the metaphysics that i found deeply
disturbing
and those those deeply disturbing
patterns
they concern anthropology they concern
creation generally
and they concern the doctrine of god and
so i'll try to go as quickly as i can
through these things knowing that it
would take much longer to go at the
depth i'd like to
um but uh i'll start with uh sort of the
the
anthropology of it right so um
obviously most folks are familiar with
the doctrine of original sin and the
entire idea
that uh somehow we're guilty for adam's
sin and we're somehow crippled and
incapable of doing things that are
pleasing to god
and
and when i really looked at augustine
what what was notable to me there was
that uh what you find is is what's
typically referred to as this nature
grace divide the idea that nature can't
of its own right ever you know in itself
be pleasing
to god and and the context for this
suddenly became uh clear to me as i was
looking through and looking at the work
of augustine because augustine had
essentially introduced this framework of
merits and demerits and and the sort of
thing that became normative for the ways
in which catholics understand our
relationship to god and then that became
you know came to four at the center of
the reformation so aga essentially
augustine was looking at the question of
you know scripture he talks about
righteousness or you know justice in the
vulgate it's justity right um and so so
what is it talking about right that you
know this justice of god or attaining
justice what does that look like and i
guess then ended up developing this this
concept of the order of affections or
the order of loves and the idea is that
whenever i engage in activity
um
there is a certain you know draw or a
love right to a perceived good but many
goods are in conflict and we can't have
them at the same time so if i'm resting
on the couch and i'm enjoying myself i'm
at ease but then i think you know i
should get up and work out
i now have conflicting goods right i
have a good ease and comfort but i have
this other good of uh of well whatever
it is
but let's say of health right and those
can't be had simultaneously and so when
i make a choice there's a certain
hierarchy of affections that begins to
emerge
and so the idea is that augustine
presumes that every choice we make has a
hierarchy of love it's reflective of a
certain priority of those loves
and he suggests that the just man
building on the latin justicia which
means that you render to egypt's due
that the just man um his
internal order of loves is reflective of
the external order of goods in the world
so augustine presumes that goods are not
just subjective they're objective right
god is really superior to creatures
angels are superior to man man secured
animals and so on and so forth down the
chain
uh and so he suggests that uh the order
of loves of the just man mirrors the
order of goods in in the cosmos
and so early on when augustine is
dealing with this this question and he's
like okay so what do i do
if i look inside and i realize i have
disordered loves
and early august and pre-pelagius he
says well you you just will to fix it
right you just change it right and then
the pelagian dispute comes along and
there's this entire uh dispute uh
prompted well less so by pelagius
um but more so by his disciple celestias
but nonetheless the pelagian dispute
kicks off
and um and augustine's facing this
question well in what sense is salvation
from god or in what sense is it from
grace if it's just me willing certain
orders of loves and those things are
pleasing to god uh what is god doing in
this and so this is where augustine
dealing with the pelagians introduces
this framework that really suggests well
you know um actually
uh my order of loves is uh you know it's
it's actually not in my control to make
it just what i need is i need god to
come in and i need him to fix that order
of love so that i can do deeds that are
just and that are pleasing and
meritorious before god and this is where
the later development of the concept of
original sin comes from that there's not
only an inheritance of adam's guilt but
there's also an inherited distorted
order of gloves that i can't fix now
augustine admits like sure you can go
ahead and you can choose to steal or not
steal murder or not murder but insofar
as it's coming from these disordered
loves it's never pleasing to god this is
a necessity of sin right it's always
corrupt it's always sinful and so on and
so you need this sort of supernatural
intervention where god flips those order
of gloves
and suddenly it gives you uh you know
internal affections from which you can
do things that are pleasing to him and
then to make sure that pelagius didn't
have a leg stand on he suggests that
even in eden before the fall
even though adam could have done things
that were pleasing to god it was only
because of this prior grace
that you know comes into the that that's
there already from the outside what he
calls original righteousness uh the
other stuff post fall is called at least
you know by the time a trent called for
benign grace but in in eden it's you
know this original righteousness that's
there that's holding adam's order of
loves together
well the end result what you get there
is you get uh you get a couple of
different things that start to emerge
right the one thing that you get is
this sense that nature
really doesn't have the resources in
itself to ever be good right ever to be
truly pleasing to god uh on its own
there's always this need for this sort
of supernatural intervention that adds a
little something to nature in order to
hold up the capacity to do good it's
true pre-fall it's true post fall um and
this is what's called the nature of
grace divide that nature is incomplete
on its own it's a capable of sort of
rising up to the level it should to to
produce merits
you know before god um and then that
brings with it also an inevitable um
both anthropology and theology
so on the theology side what you end up
getting is you get augustine insisting
that um
that essentially somebody who is corrupt
let's say me i'm i'll pick myself so as
to not pick on anybody right i come into
the world and i have guilt from adam
well i'm already not owed anything from
god other than justice or punishment
because i'm guilty for sins
um but then also because i have these
distorted order of gloves even if i try
to do good things i end up doing corrupt
things that are sinful and so again i'm
only owed uh punishment from god and so
what's needed is an act of mercy on
god's part but because i'm already owed
punishment god doesn't have to give
mercy and so this introduces a sense of
arbitrariness on god's part he could
show mercy he could not right sort of up
to him we should be grateful if he does
not surprised if he doesn't still praise
him for his justice if he damns me all
that sort of stuff
uh and that's sort of the initiation of
this type of volunteerism that happens
in god where it's it's all in some sense
arbitrary in the true sense of arbitrium
right it's just god's choice what he
wants to do
um and then also on the nature side and
the anthropology side it ends up
creating this sense that you know any
any optimistic notion of human nature is
inherently flawed and it's inherently
flawed because if we really understand
what i am without this sort of
supernatural underpinning i can't do
anything that would ever be pleasing to
god and so if there's you know that
necessity of sin that's sitting there
um
and this this is the sort of way of
looking at god and at man and some of
the doctrines that emerged that struck
me as inherently problematic
uh
i realized that many christians
are committed to you know trying to
defend god and so they want to say well
you know they'll they'll go to the the
you know the defense that says well sure
you know i mean
you know you know god is just we should
be
thankful that he saves anybody right and
that's sort of the nice formal argument
but when we really look at this question
i think you know the more honest folks
who are like well so if i come into the
world crippled incapable of doing
anything pleasing to god and god decides
to uh send me to hell and i'm gonna burn
forever and i had no capacity in order
to undo that uh that just seems
actually evil right it seems
it seems unfair it seems unjust it
doesn't seem good
um and also i think there's you know
anybody who wants to look at human
nature and i say i think there's
something in there right that is good
even though we're all flawed and we have
problems uh you know the augustinian
anthropology is so pessimistic that it's
really hard for folks like that to be
who see uh something in humanity that
that's always redeemable uh that
that strikes us as problematic to read
augustine in the confessions like going
on and on about you know the pride of an
infant that has the audacity to gnash
its teeth and demand that it has its
mother's breast and you know just seems
too cynical of an anthropology
and uh and also in terms of the cosmos
itself
i think myself like the other nuns it's
it's very difficult to suggest that
somehow there is this innate deficiency
in nature right um
that that that you see in augustine
anyway uh this is a much much larger
longer conversation but the point is
that what i started to see in in god in
the picture of god what i started to see
in the picture man what i started seeing
the picture of the cosmos it just seemed
untenable to me uh it seemed to violate
the intuitions that i had in terms of
what i saw about you know what i saw as
the sort of redemptive root in in human
persons it seemed to denigrate in some
ways the the goodness that i saw in
creation and and the real problem with
the with the theology of it was that
everything that i embraced in terms of
the most natural tether that i had to
god was actually in the realm of of
conscience
right and so the entire idea that
somehow i look out into the world and i
see these transcendent values like
beauty or i see moral values or things
like that those were the things that
from what where i would come down
philosophically was the idea that those
are the intuitions
that grab hold of something transcendent
a transcendent root that's not just
there in the material facts and which
are my clearest through lines
identifying who god is and so if there
are certain doctrines that are emerging
that are obviously violating my moral
intuitions which things like original
sin did
um
then this seems problematic as as
embracing this as somehow a true
theology okay so long prelude uh to
reaching the eastern church fathers um
when i started reading reading the
eastern church fathers i found that
so much of what they considered
problematic or what i considered
problematic i should say
in this sort of latin augustinian
western christianity and i had rejected
and overtly opposed
i found first of all not only did they
not have those doctrines they did not
have the doctrine of original sin the
way augustine did they didn't have the
nature of grace divide the way augustine
did they did not have an arbitrary deity
the way augustine
and i say augustine but i mean it
flowers of course into scholastics and
beyond into reformation post
reformations class theology catholic and
protestant
um not only did they not have those
doctrines when they did speak on those
topics i saw a very different sort of
theology that was there a very different
uh way of looking so i saw for example
that in their anthropology
i thought it was fascinating that when
they looked at the doctrine that man is
an image of god right from genesis they
were an icon of god
that you really had this robust theology
of image right so plato talks about two
different types of image one that is
sort of non-substantial like shadows
right um and but then these other types
of images like reflections uh have some
sort of you know substantial connection
so
they're a substantial thing and plato of
course is always interested in
definitions and essential properties
right square is four-sided whatever it
may be
uh when he's looking at the definition
of what is an image something that
really intrigues him is the fact that
images are essentially referential right
it is an image of and you need to fill
in the blanket and refer to something
that's not it namely its archetype and i
see this you know this this comes
through in some of the ancient talk of
idolatry as well as images in the old
testament but the church fathers really
see it
as significant to anthropology because
if what we are is images of god they
presume that essential to us as human
beings is that we have a connection with
our architect which is god and so the
stark contrast between nature grace is
actually that there is an essential
unbreakable connection between me
and god and it's that connection that
actually makes me susceptible to
participating in god and so the fall
rather than being sort of this loss of
some you know arbitrary gift that god
may or may not give
really had to do with just a distortion
or a covering or a tarnishing of
something that's there and redemption
had to do with sort of untwisting that
or unbearing it because essential the
human nature was this sort of root
connection with god that could never be
broken or destroyed um which was such a
stark contrast with the nature of grace
divide
um when talking about god you know the
idea that god essentially wills the good
of creatures
such that people like atheists suggest
it would be unworthy of god right it's
out of step with god's character if you
know if humanity falls demonic schemes
take over and he doesn't redeem us right
like that's inconceivable and in fact uh
it's interesting when you look at
certain things like the philippelli of
uh origin
uh which is edited by you know um
uh so it's sort of a proved text of
origin uh the ways in which when they
look at this it's
it's really sort of certain readings of
scripture such as romans nine where you
know where god maybe sort of just
chooses moses to bless and pharaoh to
destroy which is a sort of common
western trend at least in certain
theological circles they dismiss that as
obviously false like it's not even a
possible reading worth entertaining
because it's so out of step with how
they see god
so so far from an arbitrary character
there's this sort of insistence on the
goodness of god that drives toward the
providential care for and redemption of
the creature um and that is this
relentless pursuit uh that sort of
always serves as a buttress against any
sort of arbitrary
um you know dealings with humanity of
the kind that you would see in the
augustinian theology and then with that
uh you see this intersection between
nature and man
uh where it's not just the idea that we
are made to participate in god that god
is some way meant to be eminent within
us as icons of god but that's also meant
to go from us to the rest of the cosmos
so far from this sort of lowly picture
of nature
uh as some sort of thing that's you know
is on this lower level of a nature grace
divide nature has again the sort of
destiny of participating in god becoming
a conduit or vehicle for god uh and the
tether to that which is you know the
icons of god man for example uh have
this unseverable you know connection
with it and then even in terms of
redemption what you see is that
redemption is really seen as the creator
god of self entering the creation in
order to redeem it and restore it from
within because god is so relentless in
that pursuit of the creature
so when i started to see that picture
the contrast was so stark between the
systems of western scholasticism which
then persisted in various forms of
modern philosophy people like blindness
and what i saw in the eastern fathers
and that shift that took place was so
monumental
what i really saw there
was that all of the intuitions that i
had from the god of the philosophers i
was kind of trying to construct you know
this something that was a cohesive way
of holding together my moral intuitions
spiritual intuitions and all the rest um
i realized that i didn't need to
construct it right it was already there
and these fathers and not only were they
claiming that it was there it wasn't
just sort of a system of philosophy
according to them right it was
it was it was the system of the cosmos
right because it was rooted in
in the very facts of the nature of the
world itself and this event of the
incarnation so
that's i mean i i think i totally uh i
would say i totally vibe with what
you're saying in terms of the the
difference i find it interesting
that because
when you were talking about this
hierarchy of loves i actually just did a
conference for a college here in ontario
about uh about dante and his hierarchy
of loves and in i feel like they're
still like even in the west there was
still some because in dante you get a
sense in which the world you could see
it in different ways like you could see
the world as this this permeation of
god's love that descends through
different intermediaries all the way
down
into hell or you could see it the other
way which is levels of separation
depending on how your loves are oriented
so
it seems like it's there's still
possibility within
within even the
at least the western storytelling to
find versions of something which is more
like uh the notion of god's love which
actually fills up the world and is you
know like the idea that like san fran's
notion that
that the fire in hell is god's love
basically you know that it's actually
the this fullness of reality um
and so anyways i just thought of that
because i just did a conference on that
on this idea of like of of the the how
the goods fit into each other in dante's
scheme let's say yeah well i do think
you're right when you look at also i
mean another place you could look as
bonaventure right so
um
you know so you do see especially i
think in franciscan strands
especially but not exclusively in the
franciscans i think you do see these
remnants of this sort of cascading
divinity which is really i think the
picture that's there where when you look
at the eastern fathers and you look at
the idea of what the cosmos
untainted you know unfallen is supposed
to be and then what is supposed to
become again through redemption what you
really do see is this sort of uh you
know this trinitarian sort of uh sharing
of divinity right in the sense that you
have the father who has you know the
divine nature and gives it to the sun by
beginning in the spirit by spiration and
then that these are supposed to then
cascade down into the hierarchies of
angels right you know that you know the
nine the nine hierarchies that you see
there where there are higher angels and
lower angels and some have a greater
capacity for god than others and it sort
of cascades down into these which then
cascades into the lower order of angels
and then they're ministering spirits who
are supposed to in some ways cascade
administered to us as human beings but
human beings being this sort of hybrid
of spirituality and organism who have
within us the material of the cosmos is
supposed to then cascade from us to
lower things you know such as animals
and plants and all things are supposed
to participate um to whatever degree
they're they're able right and this is
where i think an analogy i always like
to use
is to think in terms of you know the
sort of creative genius of a musician
like um let's say you know we'll just
use bach as shorthand uh and if we had
bach here and we wanted to show forth
his genius and let an instrument
participate in it if we handed him a
triangle right
he he can't do too much with that right
i'm sure he could do things that would
impress us more than i could do all that
but it's very limited it's inherently
very limited in its capacity yes the
nature of the object itself yeah yeah
and whereas we give him a piano that's a
totally different story
yeah but the triangle can participate in
the good
fully
right to the extent that it can like a
rock can participate in the good fully
to the extent that it can
actually it can't participate more in
god without actually abandoning its own
nature like it has to in order to
preserve its identity it has to be at
its level let's say yes and yet then if
we place it in the context of an
orchestra it has a greater share in it
right in the sense that now the triangle
even though it's it's still bind by its
inherent limitations it's sort of
wrapped up in this larger participation
of an orchestra itself and that's really
what you see there when you're talking
about this cascading divinity all things
participating in god to the extent their
nature allows it and yet
because there is this broader
participation in the whole of the cosmic
organism even the things that are lower
and have limited capacities like rocks
end up participating in greater degrees
than they could on their own so i think
you see that that's that's clearly the
picture of the eastern church fathers
and the way they see the cosmos and i
think you're right to see people groping
toward that or trying to retain that in
some ways in various aspects of the
latin
west but i think this goes to another
area that struck me as critical in terms
of difference between east and west and
this has to do with the topics of divine
simplicity and the essence energies
distinction that you end up seeing there
so in the latin west one of the
critical moments that happens in
augustine's own thinking is this idea
that god is a super uh super simple
essence right is the term that he ends
up using
um and this is largely due to his the
influence of paganism now i'm not doing
that dirty trick where you say like oh
it's platonism so it's bad uh actually
big fan plato big fan uh a lot of truth
there uh big fan uh and and i think
there's a lot of resonance in you know
between plato and the eastern church
fathers and things like that yeah um but
augustine probably had a little too much
fondness for plato i believe the quote
went something like i am convinced i
will find nothing in the writings of the
plaintiffs that conflict with holy
scripture probably is a tad too
optimistic right there but
um but nonetheless this idea that you
know working within a certain
understanding of platonism the the
framework augustine ends up adopting is
that really what you have is you have
the forms right these archetypes
that are the models for
uh for material instances right so you
have the archetypal square of
four-sidedness equal length and then you
have instances of square and the
instances are always related to
materiality right and that's where you
get definite size and you get color and
you can also have imperfections and
number and all that sort of stuff
um and uh and yet the forms transcend
all of that and so they transcend those
sorts of accidental properties but then
for augustine you know god is you know
the good or the form of the good that
transcends even those other forms and so
there's a certain simplicity that
emerges there that's even above that of
the forms because a square for example
has foresight in this equal length it's
complex right so it's it's essential but
it's not simple right and god is beyond
even that well that creates all sorts of
challenges that basically set the tone
for most of what the scholastics are
going back and forth about
it says all sorts of challenges
uh for scholastic theology
um precisely because when you start to
ask these questions like well i mean
there's obvious ones like the trinity if
you have super simple essence how do you
have several persons but even uh issues
like divine knowledge right if god
doesn't have accidental properties
because accidental properties like you
know color or size these shifting
properties are properties of matter and
god is above all that um and god can
know that i'm you know waving my hand
right now isn't that a shifting property
in god or if i make a free choice and my
choice could be otherwise doesn't mean
that's that's a property in god that
could be otherwise and so how do you
have god have knowledge of the world or
how do you have god make free choices
himself if three choices are choices
that could have been otherwise
and all these sorts of things that
unfold in scholastic thought that become
major problems for how to embrace this
sort of form of uh you know this form of
theology or you know the plagueism the
simplicity doctrine um while still
affirming the things of christianity uh
and and one of the things that you begin
to see is one of the standard solutions
in terms of how they deal with this is
basically internal relations versus
external relations uh and so the trinity
is an internal relation the super simple
essence relating to itself as
father and in this sense it produces a
relation also an identity not only his
father but also son and the love between
those and things like that
so it tries to make the trinity not an
additional property or something like
that but a relational sort of phenomena
out of sort of the essence self-relating
and then you have external relations
where you know god is the first cause
affects
the material world in certain way and
the effects are external relations of
god that in some ways sort of solve this
problem and that's how they try to do it
incidentally personally i think most of
these solutions don't actually work in
solving this problem but nonetheless
they they do their darndest to make sure
that they they they try to make them
work but i think the big challenge that
you see is because of the doctrine of
simplicity of that particular form of
the doctrine of simplicity
god is never really eminent
uh in creation in the way it would be in
the eastern fathers so grace for example
officially according to catholic church
right this this thing
it's
it's created right it is created grace
and why is it created well because it's
an effect right when you're talking
about the presence of god he's present
via the effect so my order of love
shifts because of convenient grace and
now i have an order of loves from which
i can if i freely cooperate you know
produce deeds that are meritorious
before god but that's not in in any way
a part of god in me right this is god is
in me via the effect that has been
brought upon me and that's why grace is
ultimately created because it's all
creature over here
whereas for the eastern fathers
yes they talk about divine simplicity
um but when you look at their talk of
divine simplicity there's all sorts of
ways in which it's very different than
that so um gregory misses very clear
no means that yes the divine essence is
simple right whatever god is is one
thing this you know
the divine nature is simple but he says
you know but the persons aren't right
there's three of them and then you see
people like basil caesarea saying well
the essence is one but the energies that
exude from it and you know those are you
know how many they're they're
innumerable yeah and so they start to
draw these sorts of distinctions um and
and the reason this is critical is um
because when you look at the i'm sure
you know this about the essence energies
but rather than presuming that all your
you know listeners do
um i mean the basic concept of this
essence energy's distinction
is uh you know
the term energy emerges from aristotle
right and it initially emerges in the
context of the unmoved mover and refers
to a certain type of activity right so
aristotle being convinced that all this
mutated changing stuff in our world has
to stand upon something that's
unchanging right that doesn't mutate he
had to draw
develop a term that refers to that type
of perfect non-mutated activity
that his god would do and so he draws
the distinction between kinesis which is
progressive incomplete you know changing
motion like building a house you know it
goes through stages
versus complete or perfect activity like
seeing every time i look at you it's
complete in that moment
um and then the alexandrian jews thought
this was really useful way of talking
about god and his activity and so they
start to embrace this but unlike
aristotle who had said that god's
essence is energia right he is just
nothing but pure you know perfect
activity um
the alexandria jews drew a distinction
between god's face and his back drawing
from the story of moses right show me
your glory and he says i'll show you my
face i can't show you my face i might
see my face and lip but i'll show you my
back
um which became interpreted at least in
people like philo of alexandria like the
distinction between god's essence who he
is in himself and the energies those
aspects that exude from
god and come down to us and convey who
he is
and then that distinction plays its way
out in a couple of different ways in
alexandria judaism there was also this
notion of transference where the
operative powers that express a nature
in some ways communicable so the
favorite
metaphor or the favorite analogy for the
church fathers is always fire and metal
right they stick metal and fire and then
it starts to glow and burn and you
remove it and now it has the energies
right or the energy of fire
in it of heating and lighting it's still
metal right but something of the nature
of fire has been communicated to it and
that became the way of explaining things
like demoniacs how are how are demoniacs
have secret knowledge or superhuman
strength or whatever it is they're
participating they're energized by those
things right they're participating in
the foreign nature the energies of that
foreign nature um and it also became how
they explain prophets right energized by
you know god or or by the holy angels
and second maccabees yeah holy fields
that energies the maccabees for war and
so and that ends up in the new testament
and then in the church fathers it's
critical because they understand this is
part of how you have two natures of
christ that don't get confused and yet
they commune with each other right the
one energizing the other um and it also
became critical to their understanding
of us and what is it that we're doing in
christianity what is it that we hope for
uh participating in the nature of god
um now the reason but there's a way it's
important to specify that the energies
of god are god like it yes they're not
seen as a lower even though there's a
distinction they're not seen as a lower
form of divinity or as some kind of yeah
right and this is the critical point
this is where i was going with this
because
because there's a tendency to think in
very binary terms you know in the
western context of there's the divine
nature and then there's creatures
and what you get is
a much more complex ontology when you're
talking about the eastern church fathers
yeah there's the divine nature there's
the the who possesses the the subjects
that have it and give it stasis
um and then there's also these divine
energies that exude from it and what's
fascinating is these are called you know
by people like maximus the confessor
right these are the works of god that
precede creation well if they precede
creation then they're not creatures and
then you have this strange language like
they're the things around god that are
god they're the processions they're the
energies and so you get all these sort
of strange
the strange foreign language to us
that's there in people like
pseudo-dionysius and the kappa notions
and yet as you pointed out everything
about that ontology says these energies
are god and so just like on the one hand
you know you don't get to peer into my
mind as it is but you do encounter these
things that exude from it right the
energy says i'm speaking right now these
are activities or operations in my mind
and they are
part of me right and they are
expressions of that mind they are
punctuated finite particular expressions
of the nature of my mind and so in the
same way the divine energies are that
and the reason that's critical is
because if
if the energies themselves can be
participated in by creatures right an
image of god or an image in general an
image is capable of participating in the
attributes of that which it images right
it's shape it's color things like that
we are images of god and so can
participate in god's attributes which of
the eastern church fathers refer to the
energies not to the divine nature
um then what that means is those
parts of god which is one of the words
maximus the confessor uses right can be
resident in you and in me and in a relic
and in an icon right and in nature you
know and in some ways necessarily so
because it's that which makes it exist
right
right
that that does make it kind of important
yeah
but but this is where there that that
divide right there
even though it's obviously it's a lot of
metaphysics that i just went through
that divide is critical so that even
though you might find in the west this
sort of hierarchy and this notion of
participation in this memory of a
certain theology that's essentially
christian the very fact that grace is
created
in the latin west and it's primarily
just an effect on the creature as
opposed to in the east where it actually
is god imminently present in the
creature it's part of god in the
creature that is such a
you know a critical distinction in terms
of ontology that has uh going back to
something you mentioned before
re-mythologizing the world and this is
this is a critical feature of if you're
going to talk about a mythologized world
and talking about uh the sort of
spiritual dimensions of nature like i
talked about with the nuns or spiritual
dimensions of you or me and the
spiritual potential of the cosmos itself
um this is where that sort of thing that
you find in the eastern fathers i think
is so critical
to uh to the to seeing how different the
world view really is even though it
sounds very similar
uh on many points and then i think in
many ways it also comes
let's say comes at a at a point where
let's say the the strong dualities of
modernity are kind of breaking down and
we can see already the the problem of
the problem of this created grace
problem or the creature as outside god
you know is is the problem of a kind of
radical duality even though it's maybe
not formulated that way
explicitly at the highest level it ends
up playing out that way where you have
you know god above and then all these
things that are created out there and
there's an arbitrary relationship of
will between god and and the world
whereas
you know this
this kind of way of mechanically
describing also the the phenomena in
reality is it's breaking down it doesn't
doesn't hold like it doesn't even hold
in terms of cognitive science
and in terms of of of the quantum
physics and these new these kind of
limits of science that that people are
reaching it just it doesn't hold and you
need
you know the notion of of rather
the inevitability of meaning is
something that i talk about a lot like
the inevitability of of identity and the
inevitability of hierarchies of of
identity for the world to actually exist
is becoming more and more
apparent um and what
let's say the ontology they say maximus
proposes for us it gives us a very
powerful
solution to avoid duality to really have
true non-duality you know how people
love non-duality like stem semi-access
actually offers us a true non-duality
which is not a collapse into a monad but
rather this this like like you said it's
like this procession of of energies this
procession of grace that comes down from
god and brings everything back into god
doesn't deny the multiplicity of
existence but ultimately makes
everything participate
in this his hierarchy of meaning his
hierarchy of purposes maybe purpose is a
better word even than meaning like it's
all everything that exists
has a ultimate purpose and that ultimate
purpose is actually god
to the extent to which it can
embed it into all these others like a
symphony because the way you've
portrayed it as a symphony is much
better way to to understand it like it's
all playing together like to to kind of
become the
let's say the
creation is becoming the lover of god
you could say in a way that is fully
unity like bringing it together into
into him as uh in a mysterious union you
could say
yeah yeah in terms of i mean in terms of
the sort of breaking down of the modern
framework the book um i just signed a
contract with cambridge university press
for my next book um which is called the
inevitability of liveness
and uh and it's because i really do when
i look at western
you know not just christianity but
western philosophy to whatever extent
it's an inheritor of of you know the
scholastic discussion that preceded it
which i really think it is i mean i
think when you look at rationalists and
even people like jakarta
uh like people like lives people like
descartes there really is uh you know
the conversation is still you know the
tone of it is still set by the
scholastic discussions that proceeded
and the augustinian roots of those
discussions and so on and there's a real
sense in which i think liven is a system
of thought as repugnant as so many
people find it to be
uh there's a sense in which i don't know
that there's an escape hatch if you're
going to embrace the western premises
concerning divine simplicity and uh and
and the sort of theology that's there
and that's so much of what that book is
is going to be about is about
sort of rudeness that lightning life is
has he doesn't emerge just sort of ex
nilo right you know out of nothing he's
he really is uh an expert in the
scholastic thinking and systems that
preceded him and of his own day and he's
a systematizer of them
is explicit about this that he's a
systematizer of them and his entire you
know theodicy and the idea of you know
ours being the best possible world and
all that and proceeding from these
divine decrees of god assessing all the
possible analytic you know outcomes that
are there and choosing the best and so i
think there's a sense in which there's
no obvious escape hatch from liveness if
you're going to accept the western
premises but do you think that do you
think that some of the like multiverse
type discussion and the infinite
universe type discussion is a way
that materialists are trying to
deal with this problem
the idea that everything that exists can
exist like that that you know all
possibilities actually physically exist
somewhere in a vast infinite universe
that kind of that kind of i think it's
nonsense but it's like it seems like
it's people trying to grope with this
problem like the problem of existence
itself you could say
yeah well i mean
i do think i do well i agree with you
that i think it's nonsense uh
but and i do think there probably is
some of that but the problem the problem
you inevitably run into is you know at
least with a multiverse theory at least
when it's used as a way to try to
explain existence itself
right it always runs into the problem
that uh everything about the multiverse
theory requires the prior
features of mathematics
and the features of mathematics are
things that as far as we can tell are
only accessible to and produced by and
you know entangled with you know mind
and so you still don't sort of escape
this sort of uh mental phenomena and i
do i toy with this whenever i'm talking
about ways that people try to escape
liveness
is that they'll they'll either go to the
absurd and they'll just choose
randomness and for some reason
randomness is better than picking them
this is incredibly rationalistic you
know rigid system
or they'll end up you know just trying
to multiply
you know the number of possibilities
that are there similarly the multiverse
does but there's something that's
inescapable about it once you've
embraced sort of rationalist framework
and that's where i really do think the
only way to to truly escape it is to
avoid the type of um rigid ontologies
and dichotomies that are there in the
first place and that's where you really
do need the sorts of things that you
find in people like maximus and in you
know the eastern church fathers which
really do find an alternative you know
provide a very real alternative way of
looking at the cosmos um and at oncology
and the ways in which uh
god and world interact i really do think
that's that's the only real escape hatch
i don't think there's i don't think
there's another
right look i we've been going for a
while i think that's a good way to end
is like there is no other escape hatch
so listen nathan this was a really
wonderful discussion i i really
appreciate it and
we'll definitely i'll definitely be
keeping tabs on your upcoming projects
and once you are allowed to talk about
your projects you know it would be nice
to to have you back into because one of
the things i'd like to
to to help people think of is how it is
it that artists today especially artists
that are christian
how can they create in this world like
how is it that they create something
that is both connected to the world in
which they live but is pointing towards
the good and the true um you know
and and the beautiful and so that'll be
our next conversation if if you if
you're okay with that oh yeah yeah i'm
absolutely okay with that happy to do it
all right so thanks for it thanks for
your time and uh everybody hope you
enjoyed this you know you can find
nathan nathan online you can look nathan
jacobs has he has his website you can
see his writing you can see his visual
art and also you know the two movie
projects that we talked about and so
thanks everybody for your attention and
uh we'll talk very soon
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your usual podcast platform but we also
have a website with a blog and several
very interesting articles by very
intelligent people that have been
thinking about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects we also have a clips channel a
facebook group you know there's a whole
lot of ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and the
discussion of symbolism don't forget
that my brother matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please go
ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support